hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar HTV the most severe form of
viral hepatitis what you need to know
about it
presented by doctors valentina vicar and
Anna avian I am Alexis Krause of lab
routes and I'll be our moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab birds and
brought to you by dia Soren
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit w-w-w
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit I now present today's
speaker dr. Valentina sticker associate
professor of biology at the department
of experimental medicine and surgery
University of Rome tor vergata italy and
dr. anna avian how do the hepatitis unit
at the spanish national center of
microbiology instituto de salud carlos a
3rd madrid spain for complete biography
on our speakers please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
dr. thicker and dr. Avion you may now
begin your presentation
you
thank you for these kind introduction
and today we will talk about insights
and emerging concept into a peculiar
path of generative apparatus the virus h
DB h VD is the smallest RNA virus
however it can cause the most severe
forms of a variety
HDV is a very peculiar since it can
establish an infection all in presence
of another virus and these helper virus
is a peccatis B virus HBV indeed HDV
uses the surface glycoproteins that are
produced by HPV to infect the
hepatocytes
this means that HPV and h bv share the
same surface glycoproteins and these in
turn means that anti HPV vaccinations
can be active also against HPV
another peculiarity is represented by h
DV genome that is composed by a highly
stable circular RNA molecule after the
entry into the pasta sites h DV genome
migrates into the nucleus where it is
either transcribed or replicated by
human RNA polymerases furthermore h DV
genome encodes only a single protein
that is defined as Delta antigen the
production of a single protein by h DV
genome and particularly the lack of the
viral polymerase have limited for
several years the identification of
effective pharmacological targets
against h VV h DV can be transmitted
parenterally sexually and vertically and
however the most efficient way of
acquiring HPV infection is the parental
transmission
in particular it has been estimated that
even very very low doses of HDV up to
ten to minus eleven can establish an
infection and these poses some concerns
on injection drug users that represent
an important reservoir of HPV infection
in particular these recent study led in
San Francisco has shown that older 1/3
of injection drug users with the chronic
HBV infection are also HDV zero positive
there are two types of infection Co
infection and the super infection
co-infection means the simultaneous
infection by both HPV and HDV
co-infection is associated with the
resolution of both infections and with
the 3/4 percent risk to develop
permanent varieties in the setting of
co-infection the development of
antibodies against HDV is the transitory
so this means that it's not possible to
define the real burden of individuals
undergoing co-infection with both HPV
and HDV a completely different scenario
is represented by super infection super
infection means that an individual will
already established the chronic HBV
infection gets infected by HDV super
infection is associated with an eighty
ninety percent risk to develop chronic
HCV infection and with the three percent
risk to develop a permanent varieties in
the setting of the super infection
antibodies against HPV develop and
persist over time so this means that
epidemiological studies amet
investigating age
the zero prevalence are based on these
category of individuals chronic HCV
infection plays a crucial part of
genetic role in particular around 70 80
% of patients with the chronic HBV
infection develop cirrhosis after 5-10
years after primary infection and the
probability of survival after 10 year is
around 40% furthermore chronic HCV
infection can also increases the risk to
develop liver cancer in particular the
study led in US has shown that chronic
HCV infection is an independent factor
significantly associated with and
increase the risk to develop liver
cancer 8vb pathogenicity can be also
modulated by viral genetic variability
in particular HDV is characterized by a
high degree of genetic variability that
has allowed the virus to spread into 8
different genotypes the study shows that
genotype 1 is associated with a lower
survival rate than genotype 2 a peculiar
case either is characterized by genotype
3 that is the most divergent in the
genotype in particular genotype 3 has
been associated with severe aggressive
forms of a variety and with outbreaks of
the fulminate epicyte ease in south
america the pathogenetic role of HDV
strongly supports the importance to set
up a degree the screening programs in
order to define to identify patients
infected with HCV which are the typical
theaters of patients with the chronic
HBV na
vivi infection have shown in this slide
HDV can suppress the replication of HPV
by several mechanisms and this is
translated into clinical practice into
lower levels of the serum HPV DNA and
lower rate of HB EAG positivity coupled
with abnormal transaminases the typical
theater of HDV dominance can be
exemplified in this clinical case this
is the clinical case of the younger
woman from Eastern Europe during routine
examinations her transaminases resulted
altered the so she decided to came to
our outpatient clinic of infectious
diseases where she discovered to be
positive to both HBS AG and to
antibodies against HDB serum HBV DNA was
only 80 international unit per ml
conversely serum HCV RNA was around 7
million copies per ml liver biopsy
reveals the presence of a cirrhosis so
this is the typical profile of HDV
dominance with an end-stage liver
disease in a young adult however it
should be emphasized that HPV dominance
is the typical but it's not the
exclusive profile in particular has
shown in this study the majority of
patients were characterized by HDV
dominance however 17% of them showed no
dominance of either HPV or HDV and the
7% of them showed HBV dominance these
different profiles are associated with
the different response to interferon
alpha that so far is the only currently
labeled drug against HD
in particular and as expected HDV
dominance was associated with the worst
biological response to interferon alpha
conversely around 60% of patients with
HPV dominance or no dominance
successfully responded to treatment this
is a complex interplay between HPV and
HDV strongly supports the importance to
set up adequate monitoring of patients
with chronic HBV HCV infection for an
optimal management what about the
epidemiology of HCV infections worldwide
it has been estimated that around 2
million individuals are infected with
HCV however the geographical
distribution of HDV infection varies
considerably and some areas of the world
including Amazon Base in central Africa
eastern Turkey and Mongolia are
considered highly endemic particular
attention should be dedicated to Africa
in which HDB infection has been for
several several years neglected this
important study shows that in Central
Africa around 25% of general population
is HDV zero positive in West Africa
around seven percent of general
population is positive to 8 DV these
prevalence this percentage is lower to
that to the server in central Africa
however it's still high considering that
is based on general population the study
led in central Africa shows that chronic
HCV infection is associated with a
30-fold increase in the risk to develop
liver cancer and this fold increase is
higher than that of the server for HB
Iman infection and for HCV infection
what about Europe in Europe HDV zero
prevalence ranges from 1% in Finland or
zu vina up to more than 25% in Romania
the introduction of anti HPV vaccination
has determined a decline in the
prevalence of HPV infection however in
the last decade HDB SERO prevalence
remain stable over time at around 10 15
% of the patients with a chronic HBV
infection or in some cases underwent an
increase a similar situation a similar
trend was the serve in the u.s. in
particular different studies have shown
that HDV zero prevalence increases from
2% in 2008
up to 12 percent of patients with the
chronic HBV infection in 2016 the
stability of each division prevalence or
the increase of HDV zero prevalence can
be mainly explained by immigrations from
endemic countries and this has led to a
new phase of HDV epidemiology in Western
countries indeed on one hand we have
domestic patients that are older with
the long lasting infection and an
end-stage liver disease on the other
hand we have immigrants that are younger
with recent infection and often with
aggressive forms of hepatitis beyond
geographical distribution of each DV
infection it's also important to focus
the attention on a special categories of
individuals that can be important to
reservoir of HPV infection in particular
the study was aim at investigating
factors significantly associated with
HPV zero prevalence in patients with the
chronic HBV infection has expected they
suppose the high risk profile define as
the low serum HPV DNA and abnormal
transaminases was significantly
associated with HDV zero positivity
surprisingly notably HCV co-infection
was another independent factor
significantly associated with a higher
risk to be HDV zero positive this study
was also aim at investigating factors
associated with the request or HDV
testing and the surprisingly HCV Co
infection despite being highly frequent
is negatively associated with the
request of HDZ testing so this means
that HCV co-infection is associated with
a reduced the rate of h DV screening and
this can be explained by the fact that
clinicians mainly attributable damage to
HPV and HCV they don't think about the
presence of h DV another category of
individuals deserving attention is
represented by HIV infected patients in
particular these recent study shows that
around 15% of HIV plus h bv infected
patients are also h DV 0 positive the
majority of them are characterized by
highly replicating h DV again h DV
infection is associated with an higher
risk to die for and the stage liver
disease but also with an higher risk to
die for all causes the h DV
zero prevalence we have just this
scribe can be considered at the tip of
the iceberg and this is mainly due to a
low rate of HDV testing in particular
this study led in US has shown that in
among 1,000 HBS ag+ patients only 10% of
them were screen for HDV so overall
findings emphasize the importance to
sensitize clinicians to extend HDV
testing particularly in at-risk
populations and also to set up other
great prevention programs in particular
to set up anti hbd vaccination programs
finally I would like to provide you just
a brief overview on the new drugs
against HDD as I told you before
interferon alpha administered for forty
eight weeks is so far the only current
that is the only drug available against
HDV the goal of interferon alpha is to
induce of treatment or omission of HDV
replication implying the achievement of
a potential HD VQ however response rate
is very very low
furthermore anti HBV drugs cannot affect
the production of the surface
glycoproteins and so they are not active
against HDV for this reason the
scientific community is trying to
identify novel pharmacological targets
against HDV and in particular so far
three new drug classes appear to be
promising in particular we have entry
inhibitors Henry inhibitors bind surface
glyco proteins that are expressed on the
surface of HDV particles thus
interfering with the entry
of the virus inside the other side then
we have the so-called foreign isolation
inhibitors these the drugs a bit
different isolation of Delta antigen
that is a step crucial for the proper
assembly and maturation of a viral
particles finally we have the so called
nucleic acid polymers nucleic acid
polymers are polymers of nucleotides and
they can bind surface glycoproteins when
they are still inside the cell in
particular when they are inserted into
the membrane of the endoplasmic
reticulum these drugs interfere with the
binding between surface glycoproteins
and those the antigens does interfering
with the maturation of the viral
particles and at this regard I would
like to provide you to the describe this
study that has been presented at the
international conference promoted by the
European Association for the study of
liver disease the study shows that the
combination of re P 29:39 that is a
nucleic acid polymer along with
interferon alpha allowed to achieve of
treatment remission of HPV replication
in the majority of patients lasting up
to one year enough after treatment
suspension so implying the achievement
of a potential HDV cure we are at the
beginning of a new era there is a lot of
work to do however these first results
appear to be promising
so in conclusion chronic HCV infection
plays a crucial pathogenetic role and is
associated with rapid progression to
were cirrhosis the compensated the
cirrhosis and
liver cancer despite the introduction of
anti HPV vaccination HDV zero prevalence
is still high in several geographical
regions and also in special categories
of individuals including injection drug
users immigrants and patients
co-infected with HIV and HCV overall
findings support the importance of the
proper screening and diagnosis of HDV
infection and now it's I have finished
with my talk and the daughter of a Yan
will talk about another important topic
on HCV infection that is diagnosis thank
you so much
and thank you Valentina for your
presentation and good morning there
audience
first of all I would like to thank the
organizers for the opportunity of
participating in this webinar
this is about a topic the Delta virus
that is not commonly in scientific
meetings in fact this isn't consider a
forgotten disease as we have just
received compensation information about
the virus and the disease in the
previous talk I will focus on the
diagnosis of their apparent a virus
infection as I had mentioned earlier
paralysis the virus detection is
consider aware and forgotten disease by
the orphanet web
this virus is not a say not only rare
because of its apparently low frequency
but also as we have seen due to its
particular instructor and taxonomy this
a defective virus credibly described in
the eighties which can infect with rebel
RSV virus is the smallest known virus
able to infect mammals and is also the
unique files of the delta by rose genus
the genus has not been assigned to any
taxonomic family
additionally no specific antiviral
treatment for HIPAA result a virus had
been described and it may be related to
the fact that the extreme simplicity of
the virus make difficult to find target
for the antiviral treatments a delta
virus epidemic is linked to hepatitis B
virus epidemic ungass each solution is
focused on resolving the be in a Paris
epidemic however it has been estimated
that more than 250 million people are
currently infected with the Ebola virus
accounting in the African and western
Pacific region for near 70 percent from
the total all these persons are on risk
of suffering a delta bio infection
then when and who do we need to be to
diagnose the a parallel direction the
first question we have to do is a
clinician aware enough about capillaries
Delta virus
what is said in the guidance documents
well there are no specific para result
the virus guide and documents in the
main clinical societies however there
are some comments regarding Delta virus
in the hepatitis B management guidelines
of a w-h-o in the American Association
of liver diseases the AAA SLD the
Eastern the European Association for
nikah diseases and there are any action
pacific association of liver diseases
and well-a-day 2016 wh o document and
title action plan for the health sector
response to viola
Epirus in the wh o european region
indicates that most countries do not
have available data on ETA Delta virus
prevalence whether it is known to be
endemic in some countries of the Eastern
Europe and Central Asia and
approximately 15 million people across
the world are chronically
co-infected with B and Delta virus it
also states that it has been estimated
that our 50% patients are not diagnosed
of hepatitis viruses also including
Delta a Epirus infection
a decide in the whu-oh fact sheet it is
remarked that all chronic hepatitis V
virus carriers are at risk for infection
of Delta virus and that a important
additional risks o Delta are people who
inject drugs and people having high-risk
sexual behavior and an aggression
migration from a countries with height
Delta virus a balance
in 2017 the document of the European
Society of liver diseases in title
clinical practice guidelines for the
management of heavy virus infection
points out the necessity of including
systemic diagnosis of the SS infection
in the initial assessment of subjects
with chronic hepatitis V virus infection
it also and blindly importance of the
complete diagnosis of co-infections in
order to apply an appropriate
temporaries B treatment
the 2015 document of the FM a city
associated for the diseases which is
entitled clinical practice guidelines
from the management of Hep B commands
that all the causes of chronic liver
disease should be systematically looked
for including connection with Deborah
result a virus it is also includes a
remark about the a hepatitis V
recognizes in transplant patients it is
a tie freaks and this recurrence in a
patient having dealt a virus infection
whether any of the most recent
guidelines of the American Association
for liver diseases which were released
in 2018 that year and this document
entitled a bacon prevention diagnosis
and treatment of chronic Hep B hepatitis
E are the jülich guidelines including a
specific recommendation about hepatitis
Delta bio screening and they're in the
following any recommendation any
antibodies anti Delta virus
si screening is recommended in any
person having HIV positive persons who
inject drugs men having sex with men and
all other people having sexually
technically successfully transmitted
diseases also any patient with low
levels of DNA of hepatitis B but having
a elevated ALT level a medic consider
for Delta screening and finally
immigrants from areas of high endemicity
of this infection of the entire
infection in this guidance the countries
in the convention at the following in in
Africa especially Western haunt of
Africa Central another in Asia a Pacific
Ashland mid money Middle East and in
several countries of the Eastern of
Europe and some a Mediterranean region
chart master key in South America
especially emotional ambition another
condition as a Greenland we also have
more information about the prevalence
and we would like to focus on these
countries like Iran having a 17 percent
of Epirus detected people also having a
perilous Delta infection Romania more
than 20 percent more Tanya a near 30
percent or the Amazon basin near 42
percent of people we separatist be
having also a policy
affections
in this American guidelines they also
reinforce the need of rejecting
periodically those Beijing at high risk
of an adult infection for those with
antibodies also they recommend a
periodic assessment of RNA on the virus
and finally the document and says that
if there is any uncertainty regarding
the need to test an initial test of an
th t v-- is recommended
this comprehensive guidance regarding
dental screening from the American
Association might be related to report
the results of this study that I have
been presented here and it was
previously mentioned by dr. beter
and this study conclude that the
percentage of Hebrides v asian text for
delta although it is increasing since
2008 it still remains very low less than
5% of the patients infected with
hepatitis B are screening for Delta
virus infection
the same study demonstrates a growing
number of newly diagnosed a delta virus
patients from in 2008 to 2016 in the USA
with an estimation of about 11% of the
patient having a biography having also
having also a parallel state it will
talk on infection
then screening recommendations are
scared and they click our guidelines and
also according to to some other
revisions needed to call for Delta
screening in all chronic clinical
infected by a virus be patients so in
this context with real recommendations
what are the clinical definition habits
about HIPAA release Delta BIOS screening
and we think that we should ask nishan
about it and in order to know if they
are well enough about the Lempa bios
infection
you
second question is how to diagnose the
Delta virus infection do we have
available enough methodology for do it
the delta virus and maybe acquire
simultaneously with pepper RSV bios or
afterwards in both cases the available
laboratory parameters are total antibody
Santi HDB in antibodies on th TB of the
class ID n a delta antigen and a RNA of
the in identifiers nad RNA of the delta
virus is the first parameter that is
detected after the incubation period in
the acute phase and also in degrees in
the case of chronic infections a when it
is positive demonstrate an active
infection Abel total antibodies and IgM
class antibodies and it can be detected
the first one or two week after the
beginning of symptoms again class
antibody decrease with persistence of
total antibodies in case of persistence
of infections
the Delta antigen would also demonstrate
a active infection
whoever testing of this antigen is
currently not recommended due to
problems related to sensitivity and
productivity of tests and regarding IGN
class and antibodies although this is an
initial market offer official exposure
of a of the infection of the virus the
idea on class antibodies may persist in
a large proportion of patients in having
chronic infection consequently is not
always a market of acute infection
that's why a antibodies of the IDN class
against delta virus a currently are not
recommended for assessing an acute
infection this parameter has been
sometimes used as you could await a
market for a viral replication but
currently is not a consider to be under
person in sensitive or specific or for
this purpose
so regarding the two parameters that we
can use for assessing a delta virus
infection what are the pros and the cons
of using a delta RNA or a total anti
virus until any delta virus well in
regarding remain the the RNA of Delta
virus a has less stability in the sample
and detection and specially
pontification may be less accurate in
narrative it does not assess previous
contact a if positive they are delay is
suggests active infection and is
currently consider a replication market
a regarding a total antibodies antivirus
a the interpretation of results of these
antibodies in case of a very recent
exposure may require the study of an
initial and a follow-up example although
this parameter does not assess active
infection but a we know a because if
they said in the literature that more
than 80% of cases with positive
antibodies have as also a delay
detectable
okay and I'm regarding a little a
antibodies we can say as a suppose that
a is initiative to perform and it a
medicate not only active infection but
also previously contact antibodies are
more stable example regarding
pre-analytical phase and its results are
considered very accurate
and in regarding in RNA of event a virus
the troubles in the accuracy of PCR
techniques used for detection and
quantification they are related to
several facts one of the fact is that
the viruses are very by the wall virus
with high mutation rate in its RNA and
this virus has spread out into at least
eight different genotypes consequently
the PCR system able to detect and
quantify all genotypes are really
difficult to design
besides the pcr systems are also
difficult to perform as the circular
array has a height GC content and
extreme auto complementarity near 70
percent of a auto complementarity this
feature the term means that the
single-stranded the viral RNA adopts
something like a double Australian
conformation and this requires a strong
denigration process that should be done
previous to the amplification cycles and
so there is another problem is that a
currently there is no reliable standard
for any Delta values are in a
quantification assay as the current
w-h-o standard that was released in 2013
is a currently consider not to be enough
a great
a regarding clinical use of RNA
detection and quantification is
important to choose a kid for any
quantification that should be assessed
if it is paper or not for clinical use
I'm going to add any antibodies again
the anti Delta biases Aries have also
different performance in terms of
sensitivity and specificity in the
picture of the leg you can see that
method one do not discriminate positive
or negative results properly as to
assess the metal number two - as you can
see in the picture of the right
so a most marketed a test for assay for
antibodies untii total antibodies on T
Delta virus are in the microplate format
and only one was efficiently adapt to
chemiluminescence and this is a really
very good interesting point because this
allows a complete automated autumn
application of the of the process and
also it would allow this parameter the
antibodies for total antibody for delta
virus to be included in a syndromic
algorithms with other viral apparatus a
B and C for example as well as a
diagnosis diagnostic algorithm for
hepatitis B and Delta a to do it the
diagnosis of both infection in one step
this is an example of a proposed
diagnosis algorithm for example it can
be established at a disability that any
positive
hvs antigen in the routine testing may
automatically act and until a total
antibodies and T Delta virus and with
this action we can rule out the
possibility of B and Delta a confection
a we also can use this parameter the
total antibodies against Delta values to
be added to the routine panel of patient
having hep electronic apparatus v in
follow-up parameters that we can use
only with a patient with a highly risk
epidemic an Aries or a clinical
suspicion
so to conclude we can say that although
in consider the most severe form of idle
apparatus capital is not a virus
infection is considered a forgotten
disease and currently without a specific
antiviral treatment
only the American guidelines include a
recommendation for the Delta BIOS
testing in chronically a virus be
infected patient focusing on those at
risk of Delta infection who are people
injecting drugs hiv-positive or people
coming from endemic countries and having
high-risk sexual behavior the guidelines
also stated that if there is any
uncertainty regarding the need to just
an initial antibody test its recommended
the rest of the studies indicate that
awareness of clinicians about repair
originals a virus ejection might be low
and as a result the disinfection this
Delta infection may be misdiagnosed for
the follow-up of the active infection
accurate RNA quantification is still a
still a challenge and finally with the
recent improvements in anti dental
detection a one-step hepatitis V virus
Epirus Delta virus detection diagnosis
algorithm can be implemented at the
microbiology laboratory to provide an
early diagnosis of the echo infection
thank you for your addiction and now is
time for questions
Thank You professor beaker and dr. Avion
for your informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer question box located on
the far left your screen
Emel answers many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
Professor beaker we'll start with you
our first question is can we have HDV
persistence in the absence of HPV thank
you so much for these oppression as I
told you before HPV and in particular
HPV surface glycoproteins are crucial
for the production of infectious viral
particles that can establish neurons of
infection however the replication of HD
v g-- nome and the production of delta
antigen are independent on HPV they
don't require a specific HPV proteins
furthermore HDV genome is highly stable
and can persist longer inside the nuclei
of infected at other sites based on
these assumptions different in vitro and
in vivo studies have shown a persistent
production of delta antigen and a
persistent replication of HDV genome
even in the absence of an actively
replicating HPV so even in the absence
of surface glycoproteins
however the clinical significance of
these persistent infection that we can
define has a sort of the latent
infection has to be elucidated yet now
professor servo of serum HDV RNA in
promoting liver damage the role of the
serum HCV RNA in the pathogenesis of HPV
infection
has been controversial for several years
however thanks to the introduction of a
more robust essays for the
quantification of the serum HDV RNA the
role of it the viremia has been better
elucidated in particular a recent study
has shown that as shown in particular a
positive correlation between the levels
of serum HDV RNA and the histological
activity in the liver in line with this
finding another study has shown that the
levels of the serum HDV RNA are higher
in patients with apis aya T's and the
cirrhosis then in asymptomatic patients
and the finally another recent study has
shown that serum HCV RNA is a factor
associated with an higher risk to
develop liver cancer
so overall findings support the
existence of a direct correlation
between the extent of HDV replication
and the extent of liver inflammation and
damage
what about HPV infection in pregnant
women professor thank you for this
question
this issue has been investigated in 202
studies lab in West Africa and in
particular these two studies have shown
that around 8 and 15% of HBS ag+
pregnant women are also HDV 0 positive
suggesting the existence of a potential
reservoir for vertical transmission of
HPV infection
dr. a beyond what can be done from the
laboratory side to contribute and
improve HDV diagnosis and okay and in
fact we can contribute by many ways and
in first a we should have an aquarium
clinically validated the mix for a panel
isn't a virus in our laboratory and
second we have to have some type of
contact food a in a clinician to ask
clinician about antivirus it their
diagnostic habits and also to inform the
clinician about a technical question
that they they can have and finally a
wheaty i think that we can implement a
very useful algorithms and as I have
mentioned before and for primary
diagnosis and for the follow-up of the
infection and trying to do here and more
quick the diagnosis of the conception of
hepatitis B and Delta virus
dr. Avion our next question is going to
be for you also how can a laboratory
manage for HDD screening using only an
anti HDD detection technique
okay and he got antibodies a say so for
dental iris there are good techniques
for screaming in fact they have
recommended techniques for screening and
we only have two to help in account that
if a very acute infection is suspected a
very rare in contact with the virus is
suspected then it may be necessary to a
study an initial sample and also a
follow-up sample for example one or two
weeks after a with this way of behavior
we can diagnose every infection both
acute or chronic
of course if any a we have any positive
in antibodies we should submit the
sample for RNA detection to confirm and
active Delta virus infection
and now it looks like we have time for
one more question dr. avium is there any
chronically HPV infected patient at risk
of HPV superinfection
well in fact all of the clinically
hepatitis B infected patients are at
risk and potential risk of super
infection of with temporary Zelda virus
according to the American guidelines and
we can think that there is a high risk
in some specific patient having
epidemiological risk having HIV positive
people injecting drugs or having a
sexual behavior of risk and of course we
have to pay special attention to a
patient coming from these countries
having a very high prevalence of Delta
virus infection and finally in those
ever RSV virus detected patient we
should have a special attention on those
having specific clinical behavior that
is that having an apparently control
Epirus V infection with low or very low
DNA of the virus but the patient have
liver disease a an increase in level of
ALP this is a clinical suspicion for
Delta virus infection and of course in
those in all those cases the infection
should be screened
the final comment I would like to stress
the importance to set up a proper
screening and diagnosis of HPV infection
to set up a great anti HPV vaccination
program and to identify novel
pharmacological targets against HPV
these are the three key points that are
crucial for an optimal control of HPV
infection and finally I would like to
thank you and the moderator for these
exciting experience
thank you again dr. faker and dr. Avadon
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank
lappers and our sponsor dia sorted for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and them
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the conference information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through May of
2018 laboratory via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
may have missed today's lives of it
until next time goodbye